>> Speaker 1: From the Library
of Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Mary Jane Deeb:
Let me welcome you
to the African Middle
East Division
on the beginning of Spring.
I know it doesn't
feel quite like it,
but I would like to wish you
a belated happy [inaudible]
but this event is framed
within the lecture series
for [inaudible] so welcome
to the African Middle
East Division,
and I'm Mary Jane Deeb.
I'm the chief of the division,
and I'm really happy to be able
with my colleague Hirad Dinavari
to host this event today.
Unfortunately the head of
the [inaudible] section
who should have been here today
has not been able to come.
It's due to something
in the family.
But the African Middle
East Division,
and this particular room,
has hosted numerous programs,
and has hosted the entire
series that Hirad Dinavari,
our Persian specialist, will
be talking about in a minute.
It's a lecture series that
started after our exhibit
in 2014, "1,000 Years
of the Persian Book."
And that was the first
exhibit of its kind
that highlighted the Persian
collections here at the Library.
And brought in hundreds of
thousands of people visited them
over a period of six months.
And it is this way of
putting forth the collections,
putting forth the items that
we hold, and sharing them
with the public because
we're sharing them not only
with you here in this room,
but as this program
is being webcast.
We're sharing this program
with the rest of the world
because those programs
will be put on our screen,
the screen of the
Library of Congress,
and are accessible
anywhere around the globe.
So if you have friends,
people you know in Iran,
or anywhere else,
you can let them know
that we had this program today.
And this program is on popular
Iranian cinema before the
revolution, and it is presented
by Doctor Pedram Partovi.
The importance of this is
that we do not simply
bring you programs,
but we bring the scholars who
have studied, who have worked
on these programs, who can
share their experience,
their expertise, their
knowledge, their insights
with all of us to
make the collections
that we hold better understood,
better appreciated, by everyone.
And, in a way, this is a role,
the role of this division.
And the role of all the
divisions in the library.
This division represents
78 countries.
We have the whole Middle East
which is rather expansionist
because we are not limited
by political definitions
of where we stand, but rather
by linguistic definitions.
So Persian is spoken not only
in Iran, but much further away.
And in Afghanistan, in
Tajikistan, and beyond.
So our region goes
from, you know --
from the west in Morocco,
and through to the east,
to Afghanistan, and
northwards to the whole
of Central Asia,
and the Caucuses.
This is just the Near East.
Then we have Africa, and that is
the whole continent of Africa,
every single country of Africa.
And then we have the
Hebraic world which is --
represents not only a
region, not only a place,
but also the collections
of Hebraic
and Judaic around the world.
So with this [inaudible] I will
let my colleague Hirad Dinavari
introduce the speaker today.
Hirad.
>> Hirad Dinavari:
Thank you, Mary Jane.
Appreciate that.
Want to thank you all for
coming during the workday.
I know it's busy
and it's lunch time
and this is a [inaudible]
lecture opening.
Essentially every year we do
our Persian book lecture series
in the Spring period around the
[inaudible] season, and we usher
in the season and the
lecture series together.
Our speaker for today
is Doctor Pedram Partovi
who is a historian of
medieval and modern Muslim --
Medieval and Muslim
-- I'm sorry.
Doctor Pedram Partovi is a
historian of the medieval
and modern Muslim world.
His current research focuses on
the history of youth movements,
and the role in creating and
destructing the political order
in Iran and the greater
Middle East.
This project springs
from his earlier work
on popular Iranian
cinema which is --
which in its depictions of male
heroism and problematization
of the effort of state agents
to eliminate or to co-opt
in the name of modern progress.
Doctor Partovi is a lecturer,
and has given many
classes currently
at American University, and
is fluent in Persian, Arabic,
Hindi, Urdu, and
also is familiar
or is knowledgeable
in French as well.
And he is going to
speak about the book
that he has recently done
on popular Iranian cinema,
and I'm not going to take
more time, and let him start.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Doctor Pedram Partovi:
Well, first of all,
thank you very much to Mary Jane
and Hirad, and to the Library
of Congress staff
for inviting me.
Yes. I'm going to talk a
little bit about the book
that I've recently published.
Maybe I'll just show you very
briefly where you can get it.
So [laughs] it's
published by Routledge.
I realize it's very expensive,
and I certainly don't
expect you to buy it.
But if you would
like to read it,
there's an ebook
version that's $50,
and in the future I've been told
that there will be
a paperback version
as well that will be cheaper.
But yes. Ask your library to
buy it for their collection.
So I want to talk about popular
Iranian cinema before the
Islamic revolution.
Some of you might know
something about Iranian cinema.
There's been an enormous amount
of literature about
Iranian films.
You may have also seen
some Iranian films.
But the Iranian films that we
have seen, we have heard about,
we read about, here
in the United States are
not necessarily the films
that many Iranians
in Iran have watched.
Most critics and academics
have presented the history
of Iranian cinema in a very
selective manner with many gaps.
And from some accounts
one might conclude
that the Iranian cinema is no
more than a few decades old,
either taking shape
with the establishment
of the Islamic Republic
or even later
after the Iran Iraq
war in the 1980s.
What we do learn
about the cinema
in Iran before the
Islamic revolution
in these histories is
often limited to a handful
of pioneering films and
filmmakers in the late 1960s
and 1970s that supposedly paved
the way for globally recognized
and increasingly globally
oriented post revolutionary
Iranian cinema.
So what I'm doing in
this book is looking
at what's been largely
left out or dismissed
in these film histories,
the products
of the prolific commercial film
industry that first took form
after World War II, but reached
the peak of its popularity
in the 1960s and early 1970s.
We're not talking about a
small number of films here.
Roughly 1,000 domestic studio
productions were released
in Iran from the late
1940s until the late 1970s
when the commercial industry
essentially collapsed.
And during its heyday in
the 1960s and early 1970s,
there were on average about
60 releases every year.
Iran was also at this time
undergoing rapid social
and economic change coinciding
with the dramatic expansion
of the state's role
in peoples' lives.
So I try to answer a few
questions in this book.
And these include, why does a
commercial film industry emerge
at this particular
moment in time?
Who exactly made up the
audiences of these films?
What kinds of ideas, themes,
and images regularly found
their way in to these films?
Did the seemingly formulaic
elements have any links
to older forms of entertainment
in Iran or in the wider region
or were the productions
of the late [inaudible]
era simply secondary copies
of Hollywood titles, as
their critics claimed?
And if they weren't just poorly
done homages to Hollywood films,
then what might these films
have to tell us about Iran
in those final decades
of Pahlavi rule?
Was social and political
critique part
of their entertainment?
How, in other words,
did these films comment
on the unprecedented
efforts of Pahlavi elites
to transform the lives
of ordinary citizens?
Well, we don't have enough
time to go through all
of the arguments
in the book today.
Hopefully those who are
interested will go out
and buy it or ask their
libraries to buy it.
I'm not too proud to beg.
Given the lack of familiarity
that non Iranians have
with these films, I
thought that the best use
of our time today is to
simply give you a sense
of the unique origins of the
commercial industry in Iran,
and some of the things that
came to define the films
that domestic studios produced.
I also want to address
critiques of these films
that have contributed
to their absence
from scholarly accounts
of Iranian cinema.
And finally I'd like to show
you some clips from these films,
given that so few people
in America have ever
come across them.
But I will warn you in
advance that the picture
and sound quality of
these clips is not great.
Again, because of their poor
reputations they've been largely
ignored by both state
and private organizations
in a position to preserve
them for future generations.
There are some efforts being
made in Iran to do something
about this, but again
money is always the issue.
And even though there
are some efforts,
these are very, very
limited ones.
I mean there's been a sort
of remarkable consensus
among cultural
and political elites both before
and after the Islamic revolution
about the poor quality
and cultural inauthenticity
of this cinema.
Nevertheless millions upon
millions of Iranians went
to see these films
in the theaters.
They bought fan magazines every
week filled with interviews
and posters of their
favorite film stars.
I'll show you a couple of them.
So this is Fardin who is maybe
the biggest star of the 1960s
and 1970s on the cover of
one of these fan magazines.
This is Googoosh who is both
a film and pop music star
in the '60s and 1970s and
on the cover of another one
of these film magazines.
And Behrouz Vossoughi who is
perhaps the biggest male star
of the 1970s on the cover of
the same film and art magazine.
Well, the fans would
buy these magazines
from the newsstands every week.
They'd obsess over their
favorite stars' personal lives.
They'd send in mountains
of fan letters.
Every one of these --
Every issue of these magazines
would have pages, not one page,
but pages, devoted
to fan letters.
Even in more recent
decades these films
and their stars continue to
have a hold over Iranians
at home and in the Diaspora.
So a few years ago in 2000, in
fact, Mohammad Ali Fardin died,
and his funeral was
held in Tehran.
It was not something that was
widely publicized, but thousands
of people showed
up to this funeral.
And there are some
videos of it circulating
on YouTube if you want to see.
And the most surprising thing to
me is that many of the people,
many of the attendees of this
funeral, were young people,
people that were born well
after these films were ever
released, for that matter.
So we can't assume that the
younger generation is totally
unaware of the Pahlavi
era of popular cinema.
In fact, these films are
very much in circulation
by satellite television
and home video in Iran
down to the present day.
Nevertheless there's
a very strange culture
of denial surrounding
these films,
especially for a certain
class of Iranians.
And I'm talking about the
educated middle classes
and above.
And that's the reason why
I really became interested
in these films in
the first place.
I would ask my family
members about their memories
of the Pahlavi era of popular
cinema, and they would laugh.
And they would say, "No.
No. We never saw
any of those films.
Those movies were for
taxi drivers and porters."
The uncultured.
The unsophisticated.
But then after a couple
of minutes of talking
with them they would rattle
off the entire plot summaries
of five of their favorite films.
So it made me wonder what
it was about this cinema
that both attracted
and seemingly repelled
its audiences.
And this is really
what the book is about.
Well, the popular
commercial film industry
in Iran really has its
start after World War II.
There wasn't much in
the way of film making
or film going before then.
Government officials
weren't terribly interested
in the cinema as a potential
instrument of state policy.
They were far more concerned
with censorship than they were
with cultivating a
homegrown industry.
And, in fact, the few efforts
that were made before
World War II
to establish a film
industry were blocked
by various government
ministries.
So with little in the way
of domestic production,
the growth of cinema
halls was also stunted.
I mean right down until
1940 there were no more
than about 35 cinemas
in the entire country.
And what cinemas existed
in Tehran and in a handful
of provincial cities would
show Hollywood films.
Some European titles,
and then increasingly
in the 1930s and'40s
Indian and Egyptian films.
But these films,
none of these films,
were dubbed in to Persian.
The lack of dubbing meant that
film going was largely limited
to foreign residents and
the educated classes.
But even if some Iranians
could understand the language,
for example, of these
western imports,
they might not fully understand
or appreciate the plots
or the character interactions
in these particular films.
Interestingly Indian and
Egyptian films became a kind
of life saver for many
theater operators at this time.
And especially the
films of people
like Farid al-Atrash
or [inaudible].
Many, many people went
to watch these movies.
And for the film
exhibitors, as I say,
they were a sort of godsend.
They were much cheaper to
purchase than other films.
Audiences were more
likely to come
and see them in large numbers.
And those audiences, even
if they didn't entirely
understand languages
that the characters
were speaking,
the films themselves
were at least closer
in their cultural sensibilities
to Iranians than many
of the Western films
then in release.
But after World War II we
have a few individuals,
both inside the country
and outside the country,
set up studios to dub
foreign films in to Persian.
And most of these dubbing
operations were shoestring
operations that paid very little
for a print of an older film
that was way past
its release date,
and at least initially used
just studio staff to dub
over character voices
in to Persian.
But very quickly these
dubbing operations became more
sophisticated, and the more
successful outfits would
carefully choose the films
with Iranian audiences in mind.
They came to understand that
in dubbing a film they were
in some sense remaking it.
That their choices would help
to determine its box
office success or failure.
The choices that the dubbing
studios made might involve
changing names, sometimes
the relationships
between the characters, changing
the dialogue, even editing
or reordering scenes to
better suit the narrative
to Iran sensibilities.
So it wasn't just a
change in language.
It was a change in the content
that wholly Iranianized
these foreign films.
And perhaps the best example of
these dubbed films in the '50s
and '60s were John
Wayne features.
And, in fact, some of my
relatives have told me
that they can't watch John
Wayne in the original language
because they're so used
to that dubbed over voice
which was often done in a sort
of south Tehrani
tough guy dialect.
And so it just sounds strange
to them, strange and alien,
to listen to John
Wayne's real voice.
And these dubbing efforts could
also extend to film songs.
I mean one of the most famous of
these dubbed American films was
"The Sound of Music"
which was renamed
in Persian [inaudible]
Smiles and Laughter.
I'm sorry.
"Tears and Laughter."
So dubbing, in a sense, became
a sort of intermediary step
to full fledged filmmaking
in Iran,
and many of the local dubbing
studios would eventually make
the leap to producing
their own films.
The term Film Farsi or film
of Farsi, meaning Persian film
or film in Persian, came
to be used by critics,
industry people, and even fans
from the 1950s onwards as a term
of reference for the popular
commercial cinema in Iran.
But before that it was used in
advertisements of dubbed films
to note the replacement
of the film's original
language with Persian.
And the critics who first
popularized this term Film Farsi
in reference to the products
of the domestic commercial
industry were in a sense trying
to highlight what they believed
to be the negative links
between these homegrown
titles and the dubbed films.
So, in other words, they
claimed that we can't just say
that the use of the
Persian language
in the dubbing process makes
those foreign films true
to the Iranian.
Neither can we say that domestic
commercial productions are part
of our national cultural
tradition just
because they're made
by Iranians.
They are nothing more
than foreign films
starring Iranian actors.
Well, obviously I take exception
to this and other definitions
of the Film Farsi as
culturally inauthentic.
I mean a major aim of the
book is to demonstrate
that Film Farsi is one of the
few modern art forms in Iran
that has drawn on
the cultural past
to make sense of the present.
Interestingly the
efforts of intellectuals
and some state organizations,
especially from the
1960s onwards,
to establish what they called a
national cinema often involved
making films that quite
consciously rejected the
stylistic conventions
or narrative techniques
that had come to characterize
the domestic commercial cinema.
Instead this new wave
cinema drew inspiration
from Italian neorealism
and, appropriately enough,
from the French Nouvelle
Vague, two film movements
that had expressly
pitched themselves
against the popular Hollywood
cinema of their time.
And in its reliance on a post
World War II European art cinema
model to counter
popular tastes at home,
the Iranian new wave wasn't
altogether that different
in its inspiration and
motivation than the art cinemas
that were emerging roughly
around the same time
in India and in Egypt.
And ironically I would argue
that the Iranian art
cinema would appear
to have a far murkier provenance
than the popular
cinema in Iran has had.
Certainly there were
some foreign --
some Film Farsi titles
that were nothing more
than cheap knockoffs
of foreign hits,
and especially American ones.
But more often than not the
audience recognized that,
and relegated those films
to box office failures.
The problem that I
have with critics
of Film Farsi is their attempt
to treat the post
war commercial cinema
as an undifferentiated mass.
There are informal and
shifting definitions
of what makes a good film
negotiated by industry people,
by audiences, throughout
this late Pahlavi era.
And my book focuses on
the so-called good films
that struck a cord with
audiences, and those good films
from my perspective would
appear to be drawing
on older native ideas and
forms of entertainment.
So they were not all
badly made Hollywood films
with just hairier actors.
These were genuinely Iranian
films, as far as I'm concerned.
So Film Farsi became during this
post war period the primary fuel
for the rapid expansion
of film going in Iran.
There was an explosion
of theater construction
in the 1950s and 1960s
across the country.
By 1972 there were more than
400 cinema halls in Iran,
roughly a tenfold
increase in three decades.
And there weren't even enough
prints of the films to screen
in all of these theaters.
So theater owners would
employ motorcycle couriers
to ferry film reels back and
forth from one cinema to another
so that the same film could
be shown simultaneously.
In fact, there was a Film Farsi
title that was made about one
of these film motorcycle
couriers.
Well, by contrast, today
there's about 250 cinemas
in the entire country while the
country's population has almost
tripled since the 1970s.
So Film Farsi would seem
to be giving this growing home
audience in Iran something
that they quite couldn't
get elsewhere.
So let's take a look at some of
the conventions of Film Farsi.
Well, first of all, what I will
say is that it's very difficult
to speak of genres
in Film Farsi.
I mean obviously in Hollywood
too genre classification can
be problematic.
All you have to do is go on
IMDB and you'll see, you know,
every film has got three or
four different genres listed
under it.
But with Film Farsi
the operative genres
in Hollywood generally
don't apply.
It's perhaps easier to
categorize Film Farsi titles
by their place in time much
in the way that critics
and academics have
categorized Japanese cinema
or Indian popular cinema.
So Film Farsi has mythological
stories outside of history,
including episodes from the
so-called Iranian national epic,
"The Shahnameh" or "Book
of Kings" and here's one
of these Film Farsi titles
about a "Shahnameh" episode.
There weren't many
direct adaptations
of mythological tales,
although what I will say is that
"Shahnameh" themes, narrative
themes, often appear in films
of this period whether
they're about a
"Shahnameh" story or not.
So there are certainly
mythologicals.
There are also historicals
drawing
on the post Islamic history of
Iran and the surrounding world.
And so here's one example
of that called [inaudible].
There are perhaps even fewer
examples of the historical
with the censorship regime
at the time playing a major
role in their absence.
Even this film is not
quite a true historical
in that it's not based on an
actual historical episode,
although it's certainly
set in Iran's past.
I mean specifically in the
years after the collapse
of the Safavid Empire
in the 18th century.
But beyond that the
story is all fictional.
So there are mythologicals.
There are historicals.
But there are also what I
would call socials, sorry,
which are by far the
largest category of films.
And these films usually
focused on urban family life
in contemporary Iran,
and its problems.
And just as I just suggested,
the socials are themselves not
entirely dissociated in terms
of narrative structure
from the mythologicals
and the historicals.
I mean many of the socials
may be viewed as a sort
of modern reworking
of an older tale.
All three of these film
categories have dramatic
elements usually rooted
in some kind of class
or generational conflict
afflicting the social circles
at the center of the films.
The heroes of the films,
especially those set
in contemporary times,
were more often than not
of a low social status
and even involved
in petty criminal behavior.
And these characters were more
often than not also orphans.
This family handicap helped
to explain, in a sense,
their low social status.
I mean and it's society
where family times
and family honor are or
ironically have become
at this time seemingly
crucial to one's survival.
There's hardly anything
worse than being an orphan.
And the frequent claim that
only taxi drivers and porters
or either the poor and the
working classes watched these
films was related to the class
backgrounds of the film heroes,
and again also questionable
theories
about audience identification
with the characters.
Of course the problem there is
that the heroic image in Iran
and in the surrounding world
has for some time been connected
up with figures whose greatest
virtue has been their exclusion
from and opposition
to the social order.
And what some would claim
to be its moral hypocrisy.
And those who brought
to life such characters
through public storytelling
or improvised theatrical
performances were themselves
marked as social outcasts
because of their lowly
status as entertainers.
So I mean in Iran we have a
category, a social category,
of people that were known
as [inaudible] which comes
from this Quranic reference
to the people of Lot.
The idea being that these
[inaudible] were both socially
and even sexually deviant.
But at the same time more
often than not they were seen
as paragons of masculinity in
these -- in Iranian society.
So they have this sort of
strange morally ambiguous,
socially ambiguous
role in society.
Many of them were connected up
with wrestling and wrestlers,
and with the House of
Strength or the Zurkhani,
this traditional
Iranian gymnasium.
And many of these [inaudible]
were not only engaged
in wrestling, but were
also entertainers.
So they were the ones
that put on, for example,
the Ta'zieh performances, this
native theatrical tradition
that is inspired
by the martyrdom
of the Shia Imam Hussein.
But by the end of
the 19th century,
beginning of the 20th century,
the Ta'zieh had become a sort
of year-round entertainment,
and had also secular topics too,
not just religious ones.
And so what I would argue
is that these young men
of the streets seemingly that
are connected up with wrestling
and entertainment, well
they make the transition
to cinema after World War II.
They become in a
sense the heroes
of this post war
commercial film industry.
And so these older
representations
of heroism then filter in to
Film Farsi along with them.
So at the center of many Film
Farsi titles we have a conflict
between two or more
antagonistic social circles.
And a narrative resolution
is usually achieved
through the hero's sacrifice
of his own personal happiness
or even personal well being to
preserve the family integrity
of a close friend or a lover.
And so these are not all
feel good happy films.
They're often tragic
or bittersweet.
And while the dominant forms
of social organization may
be threatened in these films,
they're not generally
overturned.
In fact, the social
marginality of many
of these Film Farsi
heroes serves
to further highlight their
commitment to the institutions
of society in which they
seemingly have no stake.
So I mean the very fact that
they're orphans, the very fact
that they're sort of street
toughs living on the margins
of law and society, makes
them all the more --
Their actions, in a
sense, makes the importance
of the family institution
that they don't share even
more important to the audience.
So there's often drama.
There's often tragedy at
the center of these films.
But the drama is often broken up
or thrown in to greater contrast
with comic elements
and comic interludes.
And these comic moments
don't just lighten the mood,
but they offer some kind
of guarded criticism
of the social order or
highlight the hypocrisy
of certain characters that
the drama ultimately resolves.
Like the dramatic elements, the
kind of indirect comic critique
that we encounter in Film
Farsi titles itself has roots
in older forms of entertainment
in Iran, especially what's known
as [inaudible] or black farce
which is not altogether
dissimilar
from the Italian tradition
of Commedia dell'arte.
And particular actors would
specialize in these comic roles
in the Film Farsi era.
And some of them
came to the cinema
from these older
theatrical traditions.
This is one of the more
famous of the comic sidekicks.
His name is Taghi Zohoori
[assumed spelling].
As I say, I mean he came
from a theatrical background
and then transitioned to cinema.
Well, all three of these film
categories, of mythological,
of historical and social,
could also have song sequences.
And song is often the medium
for communicating the deepest
and most intense emotions of the
characters which certainly draw
on longstanding poetic
traditions in Iran
and the surrounding world,
especially the "Masnavi"
epic punctuated
by the intense emotions
of the [inaudible] poem.
And the two moods that dominate
in the Film Farsi song
were [inaudible] or despair
and grief, and [inaudible] or
exhilaration and intoxication.
I want to show you two clips
where this is made
eminently clear.
So the first one we're going
to see is from a film called
"Raggaseh-ye Shahr"
or "The City Dancer."
Here we have again the
tough guy, the street thug,
as the hero of the film.
This particular tough
guy is played
by a very famous character actor
of the period, Bahman Mofid,
and he's surrounded by these
female cabaret performers
who are sort of the female
equivalent of the tough guy
in many of these films.
[ Music ]
>> Doctor Pedram Partovi: Maybe
we've seen enough of this one.
We'll move on to the next one.
[ Music ]
>> Doctor Pedram Partovi:
In the interest of time,
I mean obviously that's
definitely a downer compared
to the one that we
just saw before.
Well, and of course
I mean critics
at the time saved their
most cutting barbs
for the song sequences
in the Film Farsi titles.
From their perspective,
the song served as evidence
of the film's narrative
incoherence or as flimsy covers
for the film's thin scripts.
Likewise the songs were
supposedly emblematic
of the audience's
short attention spans
which required regular breaks
from the narrative action.
Or were simply shamelessly
pandering
to the simple minded
audience's desire for an escape
from the drudgery of everyday
life in the cinema hall.
And these critiques
were technically correct
in that many song
sequences were a break
from the narrative action.
And did engage, one
might say, in fantasy.
But in doing so the songs
could also serve as a peek
in to the minds of
the characters
at the center of them.
I mean the songs are a chance
for the audience to engage
in voyeurism, in a sense, to
see people's inner thoughts
and desires in a way that
they otherwise would not.
To see their hopes, their
dreams, their fears, and so on.
Well, certainly for those who
have watched the popular Indian
or Egyptian films of the
same period, there would seem
to be far more stylistic
and thematic links
that Film Farsi shares
with those industries
than it does with Hollywood.
And for good reason,
as we've seen.
One of the biggest Film
Farsi hits of the 1960s
and 1970s was itself a
parody of Indian cinema,
and of its popularity
in Iran at the time.
And so I want to show
you a couple of clips
from a film called
"Ganj-e Qarun"
or "The Treasure of Qarun."
And this is perhaps
the most famous film
of this prerevolutionary period.
And in this particular scene
we have this character Shirin
who is played by
Forouzan who is again one
of the major female actors
of this period who is sort
of playing the role of a Hindi
film starlet, we might say.
Okay. To try to seduce Fardin in
this scene, the male character,
the main male character
in this film.
[ Music ]
>> Doctor Pedram Partovi:
So that didn't work.
She's going to try a
different tack now.
[ Music ]
>> Doctor Pedram Partovi: So
now she's playing the role
of this tough guy hero.
You can imagine what
his reaction will be.
[ Music ]
>> Doctor Pedram Partovi:
The budgets were bigger
for the Egyptian and Indian
films than they were for these.
I mean in Turkey it's not
altogether dissimilar.
[ Music ]
>> Doctor Pedram Partovi:
So we'll movie ahead
and again this is another scene
where they're sort of making fun
of the Hindi film,
and of the literacy,
the audience's literacy,
of the Hindi film as well.
So this is a scene
where again Ali,
the character we just saw
jumping around in the pool,
is dressed up now
as an Indian price.
Or he looks more like
[inaudible] than anybody else.
And he's again --
His comic sidekick,
we've seen this guy before.
This is Taghi Zohoori dressed
up like a British
colonial administrator.
They're going to meet with
the family, with the parents,
of the girl that we just saw.
And he's going to try
to pull off the fact
that he's an Indian prince,
and he's going to do it by sort
of pretending to
speak the language
of the Hindi film, essentially.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
[ Music ]
>> Doctor Pedram Partovi:
Supposedly he can't
speak Persian.
He spent his whole life in
India so he can't speak Persian.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
>> Doctor Pedram Partovi:
And of course he's
brought this comic sidekick
to translate for him.
Of course the parents are
always saying, "Well, no.
We understand exactly
what he's saying."
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
>> Doctor Pedram
Partovi: So I mean the --
Maybe I want to conclude
here by very briefly talking
about what these films had
to say about their own times,
about the many changes that
Pahlavi era social reforms
and economic programs were
introducing to people's lives.
Well, this is a very
complicated topic.
This is a topic that I go in
to in great detail in the book
that we really can't --
that's very difficult to sum
up in a brief presentation
like this.
One thing that I can say is
that Film Farsi and its reliance
on the cultural past for
its inspiration often stood
in stark contrast to the
official national culture
that was being formulated
and promoted
by modernist intellectuals
and politicians of the time.
But that's not to suggest
that these films were somehow
foreshadowing a clerically led
Islamic revolution
which some have claimed
to be a wholesale rejection
of the modernization programs
of the Pahlavi regime.
I mean almost immediately after
the revolution many of those
who were involved in the
commercial film industry
in the Pahlavi era
were themselves banned
from taking part in the
revolutionary leadership's plans
for a remaking of
Iranian cinema.
The revolutionary leadership saw
Film Farsi, ironically enough,
as a product of the
corrupt Pahlavi era culture.
And despite the long term
bans on Film Farsi actors,
on producers, on
directors, fears of a return
of Film Farsi conventions
and narrative themes
to the Iranian cinema has become
a vigorous topic of debate
in media circles
in recent years.
I mean there are endless
articles published every year
in the newspapers about
the return of Film Farsi.
So clearly the ideas of
entertainment at the center
of the films from the
prerevolutionary period have
retained their relevance,
at least among some
Iranian audiences.
I mean if there's one thing that
we can say about Film Farsi it's
that it has been and
continues to be part
of an alternative national
culture to the one offered
up by ruling elites,
whether we're talking
about the Pahlavi era or about
the Islamic Republican era.
And this is really what the book
is about, about how these films,
in a sense, are formulating,
putting together,
an alternative national
culture, an alternative idea
of the nation itself in
contrast to many of the things
that Pahlavi era elites
at the time were claiming.
I think I'll stop right there.
Thank you so much.
[ Applause ]
Sure. Yes.
>> Speaker 2: Doctor
Partovi, thank you very much
for a wonderful lecture.
And it's a very fascinating
topic.
So the question I have for
you is the series of films
that started to happen late
'70s, things, for example,
like [inaudible] or [inaudible]
you know, "The Report,"
and [inaudible] and a number
of things of that sort.
Some of them are
internationally, you know,
won awards, but some of them
didn't, but were very different
in -- from the Film Farsi
commercial tradition.
How would you categorize that
genre which is really mid
to late '70s, I think?
>> Doctor Pedram Partovi: Yeah.
I mean there is what we might
think of as a kind of realist
or hyperrealist art
cinema that appears
in the 1970s in particular.
Ironically those films are
funded by state organs.
Doubly ironic is the fact that
most of those films were banned
from screening in Iran, despite
that they were funded
by state organs.
And we have a similar
phenomena after the revolution.
So I mean many of the
Kiarostami films, for example,
after the revolution are also
funded by the government,
but never seen inside
the country.
At least officially.
And so yeah.
I mean it makes you wonder.
It makes you wonder, "Well, what
is the intended audience here?"
What is the objective here
behind these particular films?
And those films were quite
trenchant in their critique
of social ills in society,
especially one film
that especially comes to mind
is "Mina's Cycle" which was
about heroine addiction in Iran
in the prerevolutionary period.
But yes. I mean those films
at some level were too dark,
and too depressing, in a sense,
for audiences to go and see
in large numbers even
if they were allowed
to be screened in the cinemas.
I mean these films have tragic
moments, but they're more about,
in a sense, validating --
reinforcing a particular idea
of family life that the
modern middle classes
in the Pahlavi era
believed to be
at the center of national life.
And this was, at some level,
in contrast to, at odds with,
what Pahlavi officials at the
time were trying to claim.
That what we're trying to create
here is a modern society that's,
you know, formed on --
along western lines.
And so the exemplary
citizen is the individual.
The exemplary citizen is
one that's not beholden
by family ties that, you know,
drag him down, in a sense.
I mean this is, you know --
We're very in sociology really
at its core that becomes crucial
to the Pahlavi vision
of Iranian society.
But it's the one that most
people don't buy in to.
It's one that I'm not
entirely convinced
that the Pahlavi
regime itself bought
in to, to be quite honest.
And so we have these
films that are evidence
of that, I think in many ways.
And this is what the draw of
these particular films were,
more than anything
else, I think.
Yes? Right.
Right.
[ Inaudible ]
Well, I mean I -- Yeah.
I mean I think that that
in itself is also
evidence of the audience.
With that question, the answer
to that question also feeds
in to or provides evidence for
the audience of these films.
I mean many of the people that
were engaged in that cinema,
were behind the camera,
in a sense were also part
of the educated middle classes.
Right. And they were
making films, by and large,
for the educated middle classes.
I mean if we think
that, you know --
Who has the time and
the disposal income,
for that matter, to go
and watch these movies?
Certainly not taxi
drivers and porters.
Right. Right.
So, as I say, I mean it's --
It may seem strange on its face
that we don't have middle
class characters, by and large,
as the central focus of
these particular films,
but I think that's part of what
I would argue to be the sort
of counter narrative that
these films are offering
to the official narrative
of the state at the time.
That sees, in fact, the
educated middle classes,
and in particular
the civil servant,
as the exemplary citizen.
Well, I defy you to find a civil
servant in any of these films.
It doesn't exist.
I defy you to find a police
presence, for that matter,
in any of these films.
They don't exist either.
You know? I mean it's all street
justice more often than not
that defines these
particular films.
So, as I say, I mean it's part
of the sort of counter
narrative.
On its face you may
come immediately
to the assumption that, well,
because it's all about the poor
and working classes, then
it must be that the poor
and working classes are watching
these films, but as I say,
I mean historically
entertainers were
from the poor and
working classes.
So it was no different in the
cinema as it was in the theater
that preceded it in that regard.
That's why I say, I mean, these
films are very, very much a part
of Iran's cultural history.
Right. Oh, yes.
Absolutely.
I mean so, for example, the
guy that made this film.
Right. Absolutely.
Yeah. I mean so the guy
that directed this film,
Siamak Yasemi, well, first
of all, he comes from a very,
very learned Iranian family.
He spoke several languages,
including Hindi and Urdu.
He spent many, many
years in India.
He had a degree, a university
degree, in Persian literature.
So I mean they know all
of this stuff, in a sense.
And again that's what makes
all these films so strange,
as I say, on their face, because
they've been completely ignored.
They've been seen as
culturally inauthentic,
but in many ways they're not.
From my perspective.
Yeah.
[ Inaudible ]
Well, yeah.
I mean I don't know if there
was some attempt to sort
of create a national unity
that the Pahlavi officials
weren't accomplishing.
As I say, I mean I
think the main reason
that we have lower class
heroes in these films is
because historically,
traditionally,
that's what they were.
Yeah. I mean again, and
not just the entertainers,
but I mean most of the
modern social movements
in Iran have been led by
these kinds of figures too.
By these lower class figures,
these toughs of the street,
toughs, the gangsters
of the streets.
And they've always had this
sort of morally ambiguous role.
So one day they could be, you
know, clubbing their neighbors
on the head for protesting
in the streets,
and the next day they could
be leading the protest.
So they've always had this
sort of complicated role
within society, and we see
that in these films too.
I mean more often than
not we see both poles
of this [inaudible] character,
the mercenary elements of them
and of course also the pious and
socially justice minded elements
of them too or the public
spirited elements of them too.
Yes?
[ Inaudible ]
Well, I mean again -- Right.
Right. Well, for
the first question,
in terms of the ratings system,
there was a very
rudimentary one, we might say.
I mean films were
rated by country
of origin at the first level.
So, you know, if it was a
Western film or European film,
an American film, only
those films, for example --
Mostly those films, for example,
were shown in the
first class theaters.
And Indian and Iranian
films were, by and large,
shown in the second and the
third class cinemas generally
during this period of time.
So there was a sort of
government ratings system
for the theaters themselves,
and that determined how
much they could charge
for ticket prices and so on.
So that also explains
the production qualities
of these particular films too.
And so they were getting less
in terms of ticket revenues
and so the films had smaller
budgets than, let's say,
an American Hollywood
production.
And then again towards
the 1970s we also get age
restrictions too.
So in the 1970s we get
increasingly what we might think
of as films with, you know,
definite erotic themes,
sexually suggestive themes.
Even nudity, for that matter.
Both Iranian and foreign.
And yes. There were age
restrictions that were put
in place to keep people
under the age of 18
out of those particular
showings.
But it wasn't quite as
complicated a system
as we have in the United States.
And of course I mean
the ratings system
in the United States really only
dates back to the late 1960s.
I mean this is not
something that was there
from the very, very beginning.
And of course there were always
limits on what you could do,
especially for Iranian films.
There was always limits
on what you could do.
So I mean you couldn't show
or even stimulate sexual
intercourse on screen.
Kissing was perfectly
acceptable,
but I mean if you've seen,
for example, Indian films
of the same period, even
that wasn't acceptable
for those films.
And so at some level
people flocked
to Iranian films precisely
because of what the Indian films
didn't show, and people flocked
to Indian films precisely
because of what the
Indian films showed
that the Iranian films
didn't, for that matter.
So they're sort of working
together in that sense.
I mean if you watch the Iranian
films you probably watched a lot
of the Indian films too.
It was a shared audience in
many ways or at least a lot
of audience overlap between
these two film forms.
Was that all of the
questions that you're -- Oh.
And then post revolution.
Right. Right.
Right. Well, no.
I mean obviously since
the revolution the idea
of an unrelated man and a woman
sharing any kind of intimacy
on screen, even touching
one another, is off limits.
I mean they figured out
ways to get around this.
So I mean one of my favorites
is I was watching one Iranian
television show where a son is
coming back from the war front,
and his mother is sitting
on the couch waiting for him
to come back from the war front.
Well, you would imagine the
first thing that they're going
to do once their son arrives
at the front door is
hug and kiss each other.
And they show that.
But they don't.
So the scene begins with the
camera pointed at the back
of the head of the mother
sitting on the couch.
The doorbell rings.
She gets up.
The camera remains stationary.
But we can hear the interaction.
We can hear them
kissing each other.
hugging each other.
So there are these kinds
of limitations unfortunately
since the revolution.
And of course, as
you might imagine,
these films are completely
banned.
You cannot watch
these movies legally.
But that doesn't mean
that people don't.
I mean by the government's own
admission, something like 70%
of the population has access
to a satellite television dish.
Even though that's illegal.
I'm sorry?
Well, I mean there are
peddlers in the streets
that sell these movies.
Yeah. I mean again you have
these wide honking boulevards
all over Tehran, and of
course nobody's trying --
People do try to cross them.
Pedestrians do try to
cross these streets.
But you're really taking
your life in to your hands
if you try to do such a thing.
So they built all of
these sky bridges that go
over these boulevards.
And the peddler sits in the
middle of the sky bridge.
Nobody sees him.
And he can sell his wares from
there, and you know thousands
of people pass him by every day.
There's a huge sort of
market in underground films.
Yeah.
[ Inaudible ]
Absolutely.
Yeah. So I mean via satellite
television they're also watching
these movies.
There are 1,000 Persian language
satellite networks now set
up with a couple hundred
dollars and a small studio
in Los Angeles, in
London, in Dubai,
and they don't show
the art films.
They show these films.
So everybody in Iran knows this
cinema even if they weren't born
when it was released,
for that matter.
So yes. I mean despite
the ban, many,
many people are still
watching these movies.
Right. Right.
[ Inaudible ]
Very few sci fi and monster
for reasons that we've sort
of talked about because those
films require special effects.
It's expensive.
Most of these films
were made with very,
very little money,
very, very quickly.
So we don't get much
in the way of sci fi.
Not much in the way
of horror films.
We do get -- I mean one of
the genres that sort of pops
up in the 1950s in the United
States or reappears all
around the world, an American
genre that reappears all
around the world, is film noir.
So we do get some film noir
being made in the 1950s in Iran
by the director of
this particular film.
Okay. An Armenian guy by the
name of Samuel Khachikian.
Okay. And he made a lot of sort
of film noir films in the 1950s.
So there were sort
of odd attempts made
by a few characters to
make films along western
generic lines.
But, you know, few and
far between, we might say.
Yeah. Right.
Exactly. Yeah.
[ Inaudible ]
Well, I mean, you know,
sometimes you watch one
of these movies on the satellite
network in Iran and half
of the screen is
covered with logos
because they've taken a bootleg
version of a bootleg version.
And by the time it gets
down to them, you know,
you can hardly see what's
going on on screen anymore.
Yes.
[ Inaudible ]
Well, I mean the
middle class is new.
It's new everywhere in
this part of the world.
And so how do you
distinguish yourself?
How do you differentiate
yourself
from everybody else, in a sense?
And culture is one way.
So these movies aren't for us.
They're -- And you get
this kind of cultural --
culture of denial precisely
because they're trying
to differentiate themselves
from their class backgrounds,
what were once upon a time
their class backgrounds.
Yes. No doubt.
No doubt.
>> Hirad Dinavari: Thank
you everyone for joining us.
I just want to put a plug
in for the collection
at the library speaking
of this period's films.
About eight years ago the
[inaudible] division we bought
about 100 plus of all the
available films' DVDs format
from this period
for the library.
And it's being held
in the motion picture
broadcasting division.
So we have a number of these
Film Farsi genre over there
in the library's collection.
Thank you, Doctor
Partovi, for coming out.
Wonderful presentation.
Thanks to everyone who came.
>> Speaker 1: This has
been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.